DONATE WILL STAY RIGHT HERE IN
LAS VEGAS. THAT'S GOING TO BE
A GREAT NIGHT. ALL RIGHT SO
STATE SCHOOLS CREDIT UNION,
THE SPONSORS OF THIS NEXT
SEGMENT IS ALL ABOUT OUOUOUHAPPA
HATIMEHAS HAHAAND HOLIDAY LICAS
THIS SEASON I CHECKED IN WITH
THEM TO LEARN MORE.
>> HOW YOUDO IT.
>> GOOD ARE YOU DOING.
>> I'M GOOD I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THESE HAPPY TIME SO LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE CALENDAR 2022
ITION.
YES, SO , GLAD TO TALK ABOUT AB
THIS SO EVERY YEAR STATE
SCHOOLS CREDIT UNION RECEIPTS
ARE WORKS OF MISSIONS AND 13
WINNERS ARE SELECTED TO BE
OWCASED IN OUR ANNUAL
CALENDAR. AND FACT THIS YOUR
SPREADING RECEIVING AN AMAZING
2000 AND TREES WHICH IS REALLY
AWESOME TO THINK ABOUT I MEAN
THAT'S A LOT OF OUR AND SO
WERE YOU KNOW REALLY EAEXTREMEL
GRATEFUL  TO ALL THE STUDENTS
WHO PARTICIPATED AND TO ALL
OUR TEACHERS WHO SUPPORTED US
AND THIS YEAR WE ENDEAVOR AND
I ARE 36 DANIEL TWENTY-TWENTY
TO HAVE COUNTERS AND NOW
AVAILABLE AND MEMBERS CAN
VISIT ANY ONE OF HER 10 BRANCH
LOCATIONS REQUEST, A
COMPLIMENTARY NTCOPY AND WE ALS
HAVE ADDITIONAL HAPPENS
AVAILABLE FOR $2 EACH AND IF
YOU'RE NOT AND NEVER EVEN THIS
IS A FRANCHISE LIKE CALENDAR
FOR THAT $2 BUT AGAIN IF YOU
REMEMBER WE WANT TO PICK UP
PROPERTIES, THE PROCEEDS OF IT
GO TO A COMBINATION THAT ATHER
PEOPLE POPROCESS SHESS WHICH IS
KNOWN AS OUR SO THAT SUPPORT T
EDUCATION AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
PE
OPLE
OVE
R PR
OFIT, YOU GUYS
ARE HERE TO HELP US SAVE MONEY
AND BE SMART WITH THEIR MONEY
SO HOW ARE WE DOING THAT
HEADED INTO 2022.
>> WELL ABSOLUTELY IN AND
HAPPY HANEW YEAR TO YOU RIGHT I
THE END YOU YOU KNOW AND WITH
THIS NEW YEAR WE BEGIN TO
THINK ABOUT NEW YEAR'S
RESOLUTIONS OBVIOUSLY IN OUT
MANY OF THOSE RESOLUTIONS
INCLUDE OUR MEMBERS OVERALL
BEING LIKE STARTING A DIET OR
HITTING THE GYM MEMBERSHIP,
BUT THE NEW E YEARE  IS E E E E
TIME TO THINK ABOUT YOUR
FINANCIAL AND THAT'S OVERSEOVASV
SPREADING AND WE SEVERAL
SAVINGS S S S S S S S ACCOUNTS
TO HELP YOU SAVE IN AND LEARN
MORE ABOUT YOUR IN ADDITION
REMEMBER MBMBMBMBMBMBSERVICE
REPRESENTATIVES, RANCHES ARE
ALSO TO HELP ANYONE TALK ABOUT
FINANCIAL GOALS.
>> AND HELP THEM THIS ON A
PATH FOR FINANCIAL SUCCESS AND
IF YOU CAN'T MAKE TO THE
BRANCH WE HAVE PEOPLE ON THE
CALL CENTERS AND MANY WANT TO
REMEMBER REPRESENTATIVES CAN
HELP OUT THERE TOO YOU KNOW WE
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO SET A
SAVINGS GOAL FOR 2022, BUT
ALSO CONSIDER ESTABLISHING
LONG-TERM SAVINGS GOALS THAT
WILL HELP TO ACHIEVE FINANCIAL
SUCCESS
>> FOR SURE IN SPEAKING HAVE A
HAPPY NEW YEAR CONGRATULATIONS I
ASSOCIATES, THOSE CREDIT UNION
FOR BEST CREDIT UNION IN 2020
TO THE REVIEW JOURNAL. IT'S
HONOR FOR SOURCE FACEBOOK IT
TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY FOR
OVER 70 YEARS AND WE'RE 'R'R'R'R
ANKFUL FOR MEMBERS FOR
BOARDING US TOLD US THE BEST
CREDIT UNION FOR THE 4TH
STRAIGHT YOU KNOW OUR
LONGEVITY IS A TESTAMENT TOEN
THE GREAT SERVICE. WE PROVIDE
AS WE PRIORITIZERI PEOPLE
PROFIT. AND SO HIS CLOSE
CREDIT EDUNION HAVE AND OUR
MEMBERS FAITHFUL SUPPORTER EROF
LAS VEGAS COMMUNITY AND
GREATER NEVADA COMMUNITY.
>> FOR AS I MENTIONED ALMOST
71 YEARS THAT AN ALMOST ANYONE
CAN BECOME A MEMBER AND HEART
OF SUMMER TASTEFUL SPREADING G
G IN G SO FOR MORE INFORMATION
ALSO INVITE TO THE BUSINESS
OVERSTATE SEE YOU DOT COM.
>> AND THANKS TO SOME STATE
SCHOOLS CREDIT UNION FOR
SPONSORING THAT SEGMENT ALL
THE INFORMATION IS RIGHT THERE
ON YOUR SCREEN BUT THIS
HOLIDAY SEASON. REMEMBER
MEMBERS CAN EARN ONE 0.5% CASH
BACK FOR